[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 26 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 78 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
entouré de nos invités mais également
des journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite les titres de cette
édition grève des taxis de la fonction
publique les diff syndicats ont appelé
un mouvement de grève de grande ampleur
aujourd'hui autoroute bloquée
établissement scolaires fermés et
administration ralentie retour sur un
mardinoir dans les ivelines et en
île-de-fance l'Islam passé est présent
au cœur du débat hier soir attrape le
collectif parole à cœur ouvert organisé
une rencontre autour de ce thème avec
Rachid benzine un islamologue et
anthropologue des religions nous
parlerons de cette rencontre avec nos
invités de ce soir et enfin quels sont
les gestes d'urgence en cas d'attentat
comment prévenir les secours
efficacement et sauver peut-être dévis
pour répondre à ces demandes la
préfecture des ivelines organise des
sections gratuites avec une initiation
au gestes qui sauve et je vous le disais
en titre nous allons parlé de la grève
les chauffeurs de taxi étaient en grève
aujourd'hui il proteste contre la
concurrence des VTC véhicules de
transport avec chauffeurs dans les
ivelines plus de 50 % des chauffeurs se
sont mobilisés pour bloquer les routes
du département aux abords de Paris un
reportage signé Michel el midoro et
Patrick Jacques de
dixmud 6h15 quartier de l'épidor à
Saint-Ser l'école les chauffeurs de taxi
du Sud des ivines se réunissent pour
préparer la manifestation de la matinée
les conducteur protestent contre la
concurrence des VTC véhicules de
transport avec chauffeurs dans le
département il y en a vraiment ralbol on
est tout comme tout comme Paris hein les
fédérations toutes les fédérations
nationales on est tous d'accord pour
dire que c'est bon quoi maintenant ça
suffit les textes ne sont pas respecté
nos licences on les a payé on a payé des
impôts dessus donc aujourd'hui on a
vraiment plus rien à perdre il faut faut
vraiment qu'on défende notre notre
profession les chauffeurs évelinois ont
ensuite entamé un blocage partiel à la
jonction des autoroutes à 12 à 13 au
niveau du triangle de r en cours des 8h
comprend la gêne qu'on occasionne donc
nous ce qu'on essaie aussi c'est pas pas
forcément de les gêner c'est bon c'est
de montrer aussi que qu'on est capable
de de se mobiliser on a déjà annoncé
quand même qu'on allait faire grave déjà
depuis un certain nombre de temps donc
en fait c aussi aux personnes de prendre
leur
disposition
je respecte le travail de de chacun
voilà donc on prend notre en patience et
c'est tout bah ils font ce qu'ils
veulent de toute manière l'inconv c'est
qu'il nous bloque quoi je fais beaucoup
de kilomètres donc si je dois m'énerver
tous les jours je vais faire une attaque
cardiaque alors essayonsen les taxis
Vinois ont ensuite bloqué le tunnel de
saint-clos avant de repartir à
Versailles selon les syndicats de taxis
50 % des conducteurs du département se
sont mobilisé pour cette opération une
nouvelle manifestation pourrait être
organisée dans les prochaines semaines
et suite du mardi noir parmi les
grevistes aujourd'hui les enseignants
étaient eux aussi mobilisés leur
principal revendication les salaires et
le pouvoir d'achat il demande notamment
la fin du gel du barê des salaires sur
le département la mobilisation a été de
15,19 % dans le primaire et le
secondaire selon l'académie de
Versailles qui regroupe le département
des Yvelines du valdoise des hautes
scèes et de lesesson le taux
d'enseignants en grève était de
13,79 % dans le 1er et le second degré
on écoute tout de suite Bertrand mesure
représentant syndicaliste des
enseignants dans les ivelines l'idée
c'est de faire passer que pour l'instant
ce qui est mis sur la table de
négociation n'est pas suffisant ce qu'on
souhaiterait déjà c'est que le gel du
point d'Adis soit levé d'autre part que
un certain nombre de de de conditions de
rémunération des personnels du 1emer
degré soi aligné sur le second degré et
puis que si là on serait tout à fait je
dirais dans une perspective européenne
que le niveau des sales des enseignants
français rejoignent la moyenne
européenne et nous passons à présent à
notre chronique politique du mardi avec
Wilfred Richi il est aujourd'hui
question de l'élection à la présidence
du mouvement nous citoyens mouvement qui
s'est réuni à Versailles en fin de
semaine
dernière campagne présidentielle de 2012
on se souvient du fameux mois président
lancé par François Hollande lors du
débat télévisé du second tour face à
Nicolas Sarkozi quelques mois plus tard
naissit en réaction à cette longue
tirade nous citoyens un mouvement
politique lancé par l'entrepreneur Denis
Perre avec pour ambition de voir la
société civile s'engager pour réformer
la France bien que classer divers
droites par le ministère de l'Intérieur
la formation qui se revendique sociale
libérale considère l'éclivage politique
traditionnel dépassé au plus haut de sa
popularité nous citoyens comptait
jusqu'à 12500 adhérents il serait
environ 6000 aujourd'hui nous avons
démarré euh en en 2013 nous avons
atteint donc assez rapidement les les
13000 adhérents on a déjà participé à
plusieurs élections c'est essentiel pour
nous parce que c'est ce qui nous donne
la visibilité dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui on n'est pas assez considéré
par le monde des médias on on fait pas
pour l'instant partie du spectre donc on
travaille via les réseaux sociaux via
Twitter via Facebook on va sur le
terrain il est essentiel que nous
puissions porter les vrais sujets dans
les médias et au niveau des
Français on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
revivre une campagne comme en 2012 où
les sujets principaux étaient la viande
halal et le permis de conduire c'est
inacceptable les enjeux ne sont pas là
et nous citoyens vient d'lire son
nouveau président son nom Nicolas
doucerin une élection avec 59,5 % des
suffrages exprimés pour cet entrepreneur
de 39 ans qui veut conserver l'idée
d'origine et tourner rapidement la page
Jean-Marie Cavada l'eurodéputé avait
pris la tête du mouvement provisoirement
pendant quelques mois fin 2014 avant de
claquer la porte en dénonçant un manque
de démocratie interne au lancement
lorsque Denis per a souhaité lancer son
mouvement son parti j'ai trouvé
extrêmement intéressante l'idée
naturellement parce que j'avais moi-même
créé avec d'autres personnes quelques
mois auparavant entreprendre pour la
France aujourd'hui on le voit bien il y
a une offre politique avec les partis
politiques traditionnels nous notre
ambition en tant que citoyen c'est de
réinventer la manière de faire de la
politique et comme nous citoyens a
réussi à percer grâce notamment à Denis
per il me semblait naturel de rejoindre
nos citoyens de demander à nos adhérents
de rejoindre pour ne faire plus qu'un
pour qu'on soit plus fort pour préparer
les prochaines échéances Nicolas
doucerin qui ajoute qu'il veut
promouvoir les jeunes du mouvement pour
les placer au cœur de l'action et de la
décision pour moi la la vocation d'un
mouvement comme nous citoyens c'est
d'être représentatif de la société
française c'est ce que je vais défendre
d'ailleurs au travers de mon programme
c'est bien de s'appeler nous citoyens
c'est mieux de l'incarner en ayant des
citoyens de toute sensibilité de
sensibilité de gauche comme de
sensibilité de droite issu de tous nos
territoires de toutes nos
régions million de Français qui gagnent
moins de 950 € par mois et des 6400000
Français qui sont aujourd'hui sans
emploi on n'arrivera pas à construire
une grande force une armée citoyenne si
nous n'arrivons pas à fédérer tous les
citoyens autour de notre cause et pour
peser dans le débat il n'exclut pas de
s'associer à d'autres mouvement du même
type pour créer une force alternative de
40000 à 70000 adhérents un rapprochement
qui s'avère indispensable avant la
présidentiel lors du scrutin régional de
décembre nous citoyens avait proposé
trois listes dans l'Hexagone en Verne
ronalpe en orpadcal etpicardie et en
Île-de-France trois listes qui
totalisent 90000 électeurs soit à chaque
fois à peine plus de 1 % des suffrages
trop peu pour inquiéter les formations
traditionnelles et espérer comme nous
citoyens l'espère mettre fin au clivage
gauche-
drroite éducation à présent le
baccalauréat c'est à la fin du mois de
juin mais pour les futurs bacheliers il
est déjà temps de s'occuper des
admissions post baccalauréat pour cela
une des étapes obligatoires c'est le
portail internet APB mais d'année en
année les procédures d'admission
changent un petit peu parfois et c'est
un processus à toutefois ne pas négliger
petit rappel regardez l'APB ils en ont
tous entendu parler ces élèves de
terminale au lycée jeanvillard de
plaisir ont déjà commencé à explorer le
site internet ouvert du 20 janvier au 20
mars c'est l'étape incontournable pour
choisir sa future filière et faire ses
vœux mais tous ne l'appréhendent pas de
la même manière ça nous rassure un petit
peu le fait d'avoir un support de
pouvoir hiérarchiser bon c'est vrai
qu'il y a des contraintes de temps ça
peut nous servir de plateforme pour
envoyer nos dossiers au lieu d'avoir à
les envoyer par courrier si on n pas
fait de recherche avant on n pas été sur
les sites des universités ça peut être
compliqué dans cet établissement les
élèves sont sensibilisés à la procédure
dès la classe de première mais naviguer
sur le portail n'est pas la partie la
plus compliquée APB c'est une procédure
technique ce que je veux dire par là ça
n'est pas le nœud de l'orientation APB
il me dit comment faire mais me dit pas
quoi faire pour faciliter le choix des
futurs bacheliers les admissions postbac
on évolué cette année les vœux ont été
simplifiés et sont passés de 36 à 24 dès
à présent la filière est prioritaire sur
l'établissement pour qu'aucun élève ne
se retrouve sans formation les grands
changements sont des on oblige lesèv
formuler certains vœux pour optimiser
l'admission en licence puisqu'il y a des
filières qui sont en tension et donc
permettre à chaque élève de trouver une
place à l'université pour ceux qui
aspirent à rentrer en classe
préparatoire école de commerce ou autres
filières en alternance les démarches
sont là un peu plus compliquées il faut
commencer à s'y intéresser bien avant le
processus d'admission
postbaccalauréat après vous avez aussi
toutes les filières où il y a des des
concours d'entrée les écoles
d'ingénieurs les écoles de commerce donc
là il faut effectivement euh avoir
réfléchi avant voir vers quel concours
on se dirige
euh ce concours donne accès à quelles
écoles enfin voilà toute cette
démarche-là se fait pas
forcément en une fois en un mois ça peut
prendre du temps aucune raison de
s'alarmer il n'est pas encore trop tard
mais trois dates clés sont à garder en
tête les élèves vont jusqu'au 20 mars
pour formuler leur choix jusqu'au 31 mai
pour les classer les décisions finales
pour les vœux seront rendues le 24
juin et nous recevons ce soir en plateau
Marie Laur Sgal et Jean-François Créel
bonsoir à vous deux vous faites partie
du collectif parole à cœur ouvert qui a
organisé hier un débat rencontre à
trappe alors depuis les attentats du 13
novembre dernier la religion musulmane
peut-être l'objet de nombreux amalgames
pour répondre aux différentes
interrogations de chacun votre collectif
a donc décidé d'organiser dans la salle
Jean-Baptiste Clément àrappe une
rencontre avec l'islam OL Rachid Benzid
nous en reparlerons dans quelques
instants mais avant je vous propose de
regarder ce reportage de Sephora Namani
et William l et donc quand vous êtes
dans la certitude en disant le Prophète
il a fait ceci il était avec ça voilà ce
qui nous éve et CETA tout ça relève de
la reconstruction tous les événements
historiques de la révélation du Prophète
en 610 à sa mort en 632 sont racontés
par la tradition musulmane à Bagdad 150
ans plus tard il ne s'agit plus de la
même société ni des mêmes représentant
pour Rachid benzim il n'y a pas d'islam
en général seulement un islam
particulier un temps donné dans un lieu
avec un groupe humain l'islam est
d'abord ce qu'on fond les gens et c'est
très important l'islam ce sont des
textes à travers une histoire à travers
des interprétations et puis les gens
puisent dans ces textes là des éléments
pour leur idéologie et moi mon travail
c'est d'essayer de de ramener un savoir
une méthodologie pour essayer de
s'inscrire véritablement dans l'histoire
périodiser les 15 siècles qui séparent
l'islam aujourd'hui à ses fondements
était l'enjeu de la rencontre de lundi
25 janvier organisé à trappe par le
collectif parole à cœur ouvert une
volonté de redéfinir certaines notions
comme le djihad et détruire certaines
fausses représentations de l'islam les
drames qui se sont produits en France
ont é brander tout le monde on a besoin
de se revoir de réfléchir de discuter à
tout ça euh pour Ben réfléchir à un
avenir plus plus serein plus agréable
moi en fait je suis venue parce que
j'étais vraiment intéressée par
l'istoire de sécurité
exul maisen connais pas beaucoup ma
religion du coup je suis ven ici pour
apprendre et pour écouter surtout ça
fait plaisir de voir tout ce monde là et
et des gens qui sont pas de la même
religion n ça fait trop plaisir une
approche historique pour répondre aux
interrogation de chacun après les
attentats du 13 novembre dernier créer
du dialogue et préserver le vivre
ensemble d'autres rencontres débats
seront prochainement organisé par le
collectif parole à cœur ouvert alors
tout d'abord il faut rappeler que vous
êtes un collectif qui est non religieux
je voudrais que vous d'ailleurs nous
reprécisiez un petit peu l'mission du
collectif parole à cœur ouvert B en fait
si on fait un historique on pourrait
remonter assez loin mais on va se
contenter du lendemain des attentats de
janvier où on s'est rendu compte que les
communautés d'une manière générale dans
notre société se repliaient chacune sur
elle-même et donc on a souhaité
justement pouvoir se réunir
que l'on soit issu de confessions
religieuses que l'on soit de trappe ou
d'ailleurs euh que l'on soit até ou
agnostique euh à la limite ce qui compte
c'est qu'on a envie d'entendre une
parole qui n'est pas forcément une
parole avec laquelle on est tout de
suite d'accord pour apprendre à se
comprendre euh avant de juger et on a
beaucoup à faire à ce niveau-là parce
que de plus en plus quand on on parle de
gens qui pensent différemment de nous on
fait des amalgames alors Jean-François
Crétel c'est ce débat rencontre a une
petite histoire si on peut dire parce
qu'il av mis du temps à se mettre en
place il y a eu voilà différents petits
problème si on peut dire ainsi bah comme
dit marieore que vous dites hein tout le
monde a vécu les événements on a tous
tremblé on a tous su euh bah notre pays
qui a qui a souffert
donc les autorité on voit tout ce qui se
passe on fait que on a dû le reporter
bon on va pas rentrer dans dans les
polémiques les détails mais bon il y a
eu ça mais moi j'aimerais bien aussi que
avec marieur dire aussi que il y a ce
vraiment ce vivre ensemble parler de de
minorité moi bon je suis protestant
église Adventiste du 7e jour donc les
minorités je connais euh et quand on est
dans une minorité il y a toujours ce
côté où on le regarde un peu bizarrement
mais après en le côtoyant on s'aperçoit
que ah mais tiens je peux vivre avec lui
et j'aime bien parfois je fais des
formations de santé de raconter des
histoires il y a une petite histoire
comme ça ça où euh pendant la guerre on
vient chercher le noir à côté le jaune
le rouge l'handicapé et puis la personne
elle bouge pas c'est pas mon problème et
puis ben quand vient la chercher ben il
y a plus personne pour la défendre euh
donc tout ça pour dire que on peut
apprendre à vivre avec les autres alors
il y a parfois des bizarreries faut les
supporter je suis d'accord j'ai vécu
dans avec des communautés j'ai eu un
oncle algérien donc je on a on a tous à
même quand des frères et des sœurs donc
apprendre à à frictionner à se côtoyer
et puis après on découvre mais on peut
vivre les uns avec les autres avec ça
c'est à supporter c'est il y a des
choses qui nous font plaisir d'autres on
l' vu dans le dans le reportage la
rencontre a beaucoup de succès parce que
la salle était était comble quelles ont
été un peu les impressions des gens que
vous avez pu rencontrer qu'est-ce qu'ils
vous ont dit qu'est-ce qu'ils ont retiré
justement de cette inter P les gens
qu'on a rencontré d'abord on était quand
même très content parce que c'est notre
premier débat et on a eu près de 400
personnes donc ça pour ça pour nous
c'est une vraie réussite bon on peut
regretter qu'il n' ait peut-être pas eu
suffisamment de de
contradicteurs sachant que les
contradicteurs sur des questions comme
ça sont souvent
assez dogmatique ou assez tranchant et
que hélas il n'était pas là il y a 15
ans quand on organisait déjà des débats
puisque il y avait un collectif qui
existait déjà dont je faisais partie qui
s'appelait à l'époque croyance et
laïcité euh quand on organisait des
débats sur la laïcité les gens euh qui
étaient pas d'accord ils s'exprimaient
c'était quelquefois très difficile là
c'est vrai qu'on a une salle
relativement acquise où que les gens
j'en connais qui ne sont pas d'accord
des musulmans entre autres ils ne sont
pas intervenus et même quelquefis ils
peuvent être partis fâchés donc ça
montre que les problèmes sont pas réglés
et qu'il faut pas qu'on dorme sur nos
lauriers en croyant que parce que cette
salle était acquise les problèmes
n'existent pas entre nous on a besoin de
parler de faire le bilan de ce débat de
savoir ce qu'on en pense de savoir ce
que ça veut dire pour nous les paroles
que Rachid a prononcé parce que je pense
que pour nous c'est pas on pense pas
tous pareil hein et plutôt que je répète
plutôt que de se convaincre il s'agit
déjà de se comprendre c'est ce qu'on se
disait bon entre nous qu'est-ce qu'on va
dire et c'est vrai on en parlait encore
tout à l'heure Rachid a dit des choses
vraiment aborder donc le sujet d'un
point de vue historique voilà c'est ce
que je faisais un peu le reproche entre
nous bah on est entre nous alors il a
beaucoup parlé de de l'histoire du passé
un petit peu il a mis quand même des
points sur lesi sur les politiques
d'aujourd'hui sur bah le aujourd'hui ben
on peut vivre ensemble mais il est
historien donc mais c'était intéressant
moi aussi j'ai appris beaucoup de chose
il est pas historien il est philosophe
pardon philosophe et et mais c'était
important de d'avoir ce fondement de de
comprendre on comprend il y a des choses
qu'on sait par l'école par les journaux
sur l'islam mais il y a plein de choses
qu'on ne sait pas et j'ai découvert
plein de choses qui dire ah oui tiens ça
je savais pas ça comme ça donc sur le
Prophète sur la place bah de l'époque et
je pense que c'était intéressant que il
nous remet qu'il nous remette dans le
contexte donc alors moi je voudrais
quand même être contente parce qu'il y
aura des des conséquences entre autres
il y avait deux professeurs du lycée de
trappe qui comptent essayer de faire
venir rachide dans le lycée parce que
c'est vrai que une des critiques enfin
par rapport à ce débat qui était
évidemment très réussi c'est qu'il y
avait pas beaucoup de jeunes et donc si
on arrive c'est important justement de
mobiliser les jeunes sur VO de mobiliser
les jeunes sur ce sujet et je pense que
et moi j'ai parlé avec ses professeurs
puisque j'étais moi-même professeur au
lycée
jadis on on peut faire venir aussi des
gens du collectif pour qu'il voit qu'il
y a des gens dans la société civile qui
veillent à ce que justement les groupes
ne se referment pas les uns les uns
entre les autres et qui est vraiment un
mélange le plus possible le vivre
ensemble voilà c'est vraiment votre
votre miss un pe votre votre thème de de
prédilection est-ce que du coup vous
allez organiser d'autres débats comme
ceci d'autres rencontres justement et
quelle va être la suite car justement il
faut y avoir il faut y avoir justement
suite fait on en discutera évidemment au
sein du collectif on se précipitera pas
pour en faire un autre parce que là on a
quand même mis 10 mois ou presque 1 an
pour le préparer puisqueen fait c'est au
lendemain des attentats de janvier qu'on
a eu l'idée de se rencontrer enfin de de
créer ce collectif de recréer ce
collectif et donc les prochains débats
j'espère qu'on arrivera à faire quelque
chose sur la question de la laïcité sur
la dimension sociale des problèmes parce
que je crois qu'on ne peut pas faire
l'économie de la dimension
socio-économique des du drame qu'on vit
aujourd'hui parce que il y en a beaucoup
qui se sentent humiliés d'ailleurs la
question de l'humiliation a été évoquée
hier par Rachid je crois que cette
question de l'humiliation il faut qu'on
la Creuse et c'est ce qui fait que bah
les gens se comprennent pas parce que il
y en a qui qui ne donc la question du
racisme qui évidemment est loin d'être
une
question qu'on qu'on peut laisser de
côté donc c'est pas les sujets qui
manquent bon évidemment aussi la
géopolitique mais ce sera le collectif
qui décidera quel sera le prochain sujet
avec quel intervenant de façon à ce
qu'on soit le plus pertinent possible
alors dans le vivre ensemble il y aura
pas peut-être VO on est entre nous il y
aura peut-être pas que des débats on
peut faire des repas on peut faire des
choses autour de la santé du sport enfin
a plein de mais effectivement comme dit
Marie Laur il y a aussi à à intégrer des
des des notions de dialogue d'échang et
puis de débat parce queil y en a besoin
c'est important de susciter des
rencontres voilà c'est c'est c'est des
rencontes mais surtout d'abord les
rencontres entre nous parce qu'on est
une quinzaine là d'ailleurs hier il y a
quatre ou CIN personnes qui veulent
rejoindre notre collectif donc il faut
apprendre à se connaître apprendre à se
comprendre apprendre à ne pas juger
apprendre à oser s'exprimer on a déjà
beaucoup de travail avec ça c'est ouvert
he effectivement vous allez passer le
mail donc on est c'est ouvert aux gens
qui acceptent d'entendre des choses qui
ne sont pas exactement ce qu'il pensent
forcément alors justement voilà si vous
avez un petit message à à adresser aux
personnes qui souhaiteraient rejoindre
le collectif donc pour justement vous
joindre il y a cette adresse
mailparole.cur.ouvert@gmail.com
l'adresse va s'afficher juste en bas de
votre écran un dernier mot pour leur
demander de de vous rejoindre s'il le
souhaite bah un dernier mot ce serait
que que ce collectif joue le rôle de la
société civile parce que je pense que
dans les difficultés qu'on a aujourd'hui
la l'état seul et les institutions ne
peuvent le faire et donc nous avons
toute notre responsabilité dis
exactement ce que disait Rachid que on a
largement notre place pas pour faire à
la place des autres ensemble voilà
mobilisation à citoyenne donc merci
beaucoup à vous deux d'être venu sur
notre plateau et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et justement après les
attentats de 2015 de nombreux Français
ont exprimé le souhait de connaître re
les gestes utiles pour sauver des vies
en réponse à cette demande le ministère
de l'Intérieur et l'ensemble des acteurs
du secours vont organiser dès le mois de
février des séances d'initiation gratuit
de 2h au cours de ces sessions certains
gestes qui sauvent seront dispensés à
l'issue desquels chaque participant se
verra remettre une attestation regardez
ce reportage signé William l l'duc alert
massé défibrilé posé un Garau et traiter
les hémorragies ces gestes qui peuvent
paraître complexes au premier abord
seront dispensés au cours de sessions de
formation gratuite sur tout le
territoire ivelinois dès le 1er février
je crois que c'était très important que
nos concitoyens prennent conscience
qu'il peuvent être acteurs acteurs de à
la fois de leur propre sécurité et de la
sécurité de leurs concitoyens s'ils sont
confrontés à une situation de crise ces
sessions qui seront pilotées par la
Croix-Rouge et le SD ne se substituent
pas à la formation de premiers secours
que le participant peut toujours suivre
par la suite pour élargir ses
connaissances de plus en plus de
personnes souhaitent acquérir
les les bons réflexes en cas de
situations notamment sévère comme
l'arrêt cardiaque et bien entendu par
exemple des hémorragies ou des ples
importantes en partenariat avec
l'Éducation nationale trois lycées ont
été sélectionné pour dispenser ces
formations dont un à Montini le
Bretonneux je rappelle que ce sont des
actions qui ont lieu le samedi matin
donc ça suppose que les établissement
soit ouvert mais on pourra élargir
puisqu'il s'agit aussi d'un engagement
volontaire hein de la part des adultes
et et des élèves que ces établissements
recrutent au-delà bien entendu de leur
propre public scolaire pour les
inscription sur les sessions gratuites
rendez-vous sur le site de la préfecture
sur le mois de février ce sont 87
sessions qui sont programmées dans le
département et vendredi dernier le maire
de coignère Jean-Pierre Sevestre a
souhaité ses premiers vœux au salon de
réception Antoine de saint-exupéri parmi
les grands projets pour coignir
l'élaboration du plan local d'urbanisme
et le projet d'aménagement et de
développement durable de la Ville autre
dossier d'actualité l'opposition de la
commune à l'implantation d'une air de
grand passage pour les gens du voyage au
zessard Leroi on écoute le maire
Jean-Pierre sévestre sur ce sujet l'aair
de grand passage des gens du du voyage
qui doit se situer sur la commune des
essardlerois est tout à fait limitrophe
de notre commune de coignère et
limitrophe de notre secteur économique
secteur commercial de coignère c'est
l'arrivée de 200 à 300 caravanes pendant
6 mois de l'année environ et donc une
population de 1000 personnes et avec un
accès difficile nous considérons que
c'est un emplacement qui n'est pas du
tout euh propice à ce genre
d'accueil créer de l'art avec la nature
c'est le défi quià lancer ce samedi le
service jeunesse et citoyenneté de la
commune de manilamo assees jeunes une
dizaine de manicois s'est essayé au
Green graffiti une technique artistique
plus respectueuse de l'environnement
avec des produits naturels moussefeuille
et même une colle bio préparée par les
encadrants écoutz nous on a pour
objectif de de favoriser la découverte
des jeunes de différentes pratiques
alors en fait c'est typiquement une
action qui est à cheval sur deux
domaines effectivement une notion
environnementale parce qu'on peut
aborder comme ça aussi les méfits du du
vrai graffiti des bombes aérosol de la
peinture un peu synthétique et cetera et
et par ailleurs c'est aussi permettre de
découvrir une nouvelle forme d'art et
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivi
mais restez avec nous dans quelques
minutes vous avez rendez-vous avec
Nouradine ha pour le 78 société le thème
du débat de ce soir l'emploi chez les
jeunes dans les quartiers populaires
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain pour
un nouveau numéro du journal je vous
souhaite une excellente
[Musique]
soirée L